hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreign again we
have some a bunch of stuff to talk about
today we got the year for info bow all
the juicy stuff that comes with it
so let's get right into that looked if
you do enjoy subscribe if you're new
let's get started with today's video so
for honor year for season one whatever
you want to call it or season thirteen
even is called hope with some fine-ass
artwork and honestly some of the beats
in the beginning of the pre show were
pretty sick too we've also got a pretty
cool trailer that you're seeing in the
background
pretty much the darkness had stopped and
the heroes have now found more reasons
to fight this isn't going to be a very
linear story in terms of lore there's
gonna be metaphors and hands throughout
the heroes and the new characters and
the new year and basically everything
that we're gonna be getting has gonna
have some kind of metaphorical hint to
it for the trailer we're just gonna
quickly recap and then though we'll
probably a lot more info later in the
stream but for the fighting side there's
gonna be more balance as usual and
community feedback like testing grounds
for competitive Ubese going to be
hosting official tournaments for the
game which is fantastic Dominion will be
the main comp scene which is even better
I love me some Dominion tournaments the
Battle Pass will include weapons
executions ornaments and load of stuff
like we talked about before the new
armor will be coming with some fashion
as well some minion fashion as well and
your but you're gonna be seeing a little
bit throughout the trailer but we're
gonna be covering that later in the
video so don't look too hard and that
was pretty much the quick recap of the
trailer they showed in the beginning
some of the stuff we have known about
before but this is kind of like that
official trailer for the newer
uninformed players this new season /
year is going to be starting on February
6 so literally next Thursday so if you
want to take off school or take off work
definitely keep that in mind they also
mentioned that they might not have road
maps because I want to surprise us with
what's happening and they are they
really don't want to tell us when the
characters release which is cool I get
that we all want to be surprised but
when it comes to big info streams like
this I want to keep you guys up to date
on what's happening and I might not be
able to do that now because they won't
show it to us there's also going to be
some for honor Dominion series which is
gonna be na and EU teams for PC and I
also believe console with some Dominion
kind of style tournaments like we talked
about before huge prize pools they're
gonna have a lot more info on that stuff
later in the future though we also have
a story trailer and basically after the
signs of the end of time were coming
with the Year three heroes that all
pretty much just stopped and there was a
lot of hope left for the characters that
with the original Ross
and then they all remembered that the
destruction that had had ensued before
dwith past the leaders so they decided
to stop fighting and go to a mystical
place called war van Daele and call it
the truce of why Verndale really cool
kind of lore I'm super excited to see
what else they can show and they also
showed some of the weapons and armor the
weapons up first this is kind of a
fast-paced scene of what the weapons are
gonna look like you're gonna be seeing
some team colors blue samurai yellow on
the nights you get the point they're
gonna definitely want a lot of feedback
on this it's very new and they think
it's a little risky cuz some people may
not enjoy it so if you want to announce
your feedback on what you think about
the weapons definitely let them know
some of them will be risk ins some of
the characters have new sets of weapons
entirely for like them but also the
battle paths they guaranteed us that
though the battle paths will have
guaranteed unique weapons it will not be
Reese kins with just a little bit of
changes like you can see here my guy
warden with the outfit on point which
reminds me a lot of the year for fan art
PK has a new mask which is really really
creepy with a lot of spikes on her as
well la bringer has this usually fully
covered armor so nothing really changes
with him just besides the fact that the
helmet is pretty much STR honestly and
then conkers looking a lot more
realistic actually I actually don't mind
this armor lots of leather and more
covered with that armor as well
BP looking edgy as usual with a ton of
engravings on the armor pretty much
everywhere for the samurai Kent se has a
new looking face mask which always looks
great Kenta has always had these really
cool looking masks every time they give
him armor so I've really never have to
stress about Ken se getting shitty armor
or oh she seemed to have a lot more
wooden armor and a lot more detail in
his pants in the shoulder page which
kind of makes him feel like more of a
complete character the boo she kind of
scares me with this straight out of the
purge kind of mask I'm pretty sure all
the samurai actually are getting these
crazy-looking pants so definitely if
your samurai put a lot of different
customization and different outfits
they're gonna be wearing they're gonna
be looking really cool
Shikoku ain't [ __ ] around dropped a
couple racks on some gold drip for that
whole armor looking crazy also got some
ginger hair so really unique for that
character and heat so Kari has a really
creepy mask as usual put some nice
drapes on the pants for the Vikings
Raider seems a little bit different but
nothing crazy honestly is still some
nice-looking pants and it seems like so
bigger shoulder pads but that might just
be me having not played Raider like ever
Berserker ended up trimming his beard
and got some new looking pants on that's
always cool duh curry has this more
bronze look to her armor and some more
detailed pants like most of the other
Vikings warlord has a lot more leather
and that bronze look as well that I've
been noticing it may not seem great but
I feel like it's pretty realistic and
I'm totally cool with it
and your Miz once again scaring me with
the bone skull and still no shoes so
maybe next time and then lastly we have
the woolen obviously and lastly we have
the woven tee on D is a very visual
looking character now he has easily my
favorite armor that I've ever seen out
of t on D in a very long time a cape and
a new plume very royalty looking Xiaolin
kind of looks like zero Craig Abbott
although he also kind of looks like JJ
as well so maybe they really just love
zero a lot some new pants and some new
shoes with lots of straps and a really
nice looking necklace some wandering
merchants kind of vibe is what I'm
getting from him Anusha has this helmet
and a few more changes giving her this
more military vibe as they stated which
I'm totally down for and grandpa JJ's
looking a little bit thicker but also
some shoulder action going on there so
I'm totally down for the armor I much
prefer the fully clothed the JJ but I
mean everyone's got their own opinion
and for soon die has some nice little
black coloring with a cut eyebrow
I heard that mentioned that it was only
season one year four I'm not sure if
that's only available throughout the
season or this is going to be armor for
this season and we'll be getting more
throughout the year either way I'm
pretty hopeful so definitely check back
on some of my future videos for
confirmation on that but I gotta ask
where's DLC one the two og faction the
three og factions of the two characters
glad centurion highlander shaman shinobi
nara Musha did not have any of the armor
shown and to my knowledge they didn't
bring up why they weren't shown so maybe
they're trying to surprise us for when
the game launches and trying to keep
that as secrets for us to show later but
honestly I don't know where this is I
kind of want a new armor for these
characters but yeah but that's gonna be
it for most of the video we're just
gonna be talking about the armor and the
weapons for this video and then a little
bit of the trailer in the beginning
section of the stream the rest of it is
going to be dedicated to the patch notes
the upcoming battle paths and anything
else they have to share though so
definitely keep it locked for another
video coming on the chain
in about an hour so but as always like
the beef you're doing Jai guys subscribe
if you're new let me know what you guys
think about the armor and the weapons
and how some of the characters aren't
really getting anything but yeah like I
said let me know what you guys think
about that the comments below
take care and I'll see you for the next
video peace out
[Music]
[Music]
you